heyyyyyy 42 here napoleon bonaparte is
known to history as the brilliant
military leader who led his armies to
several prominent victories during the
French Revolutionary Wars but just as
famous as his military prowess is his
diminutive stature a trait which more
recently inspired the idea of the
Napoleon complex the sense of
inferiority felt by some short men which
is typically compensated for through
increased aggression heightened
competitiveness and general ass holiness
this is how it works for humans at least
but this inverse relationship between
size and a friendly disposition could
just as easily be applied in the animal
kingdom after all some of nature's
smallest creatures are also the biggest
Buster's meet the lancet liver fluke
this little bundle of joy a species of
parasitic flatworm starts out life as an
egg nestled snugly in the doom of a
grazing animal like a cow or sheep not
the best way to enter the world
admittedly I mean if your introduction
to the world was being extruded out of a
cow's you'd probably also grow
up to be a rather contemptuous creature
the as-yet on how to flips wait it out
in their dirty nests until their first
host the terrestrial snail happens to
slide over once eaten by a snail the
flukes make their way from the gut
towards the lungs where they are
eventually coughed up in the form of a
slimeball it just so happens that answer
rather partial to a spot of slime and
it's when the lancet liver flukes find
themselves in the belly of an ant that
they earn themselves a serious promotion
going from relatively harmless stowaway
to captain of the whole dumb
because once inside the nuts a fluke
will make its way to the brain we're
like the world's tiniest hacker it's
slowly but surely takes over you see to
complete its life cycle the lancet liver
fluke needs to get itself back inside
the gut of a grazing animal the only
place where it can reach it subtle form
but just how do you go about getting
enhance inside the gut of a grazing
animal even if you do control its brain
if you can't think of an answer to that
question then you are officially less
intelligence than a Landsat liver fluke
congratulations when night falls the
fluke takes control over the hapless on
steering a little creature not back
towards the safety of its burrow
but upwards no doubt wondering where the
hell its own feet are taking its the ant
will climb a nearby blade of grass or
flower stem when it reaches just the
right height the fluke forces the ant to
sink its mandibles into whatever service
it's standing on fixing it in place the
ant will stay like that breathing but
unable to move for the rest of the night
waiting for a grazing animal to trundle
along and gobble it up if the ant isn't
eaten that night the fluke will recede
back into the shadows releasing the
puppet strings and letting the ant go
about its regular
ante business until the next night and
the one after that until the ant
is finally eaten
flutes dastardly plan is accomplished
zombie ants and mind-controlling worms
might sound pretty terrifying but at
least these kinds of parasites could
never take control of a large complex
brain like those found in our own skulls
right right sadly no it isn't just ants
who need to keep an eye out for
parasitic infestations in their slime
balls we do too now when you think of
parasites in humans your mind probably
conjures up images of tapeworms ticks or
Gweneth Paltrow bloodsuckers and bowel
dwellers that are undeniably disgusting
but probably not life-threatening but it
turns out there are other more insidious
parasites butts are just as bad news for
us humans as Lancet liver flukes are for
ants take Nigeria fowleri for example or
as it's more commonly known the brain
eating amoeba and no I didn't make that
name up this single-celled eukaryotes
hangs out in warm bodies of stagnant
freshwater like ponds or slow-moving
rivers or even swimming pools without
enough chlorine when inhaled for the
nose by a human Nigeria fowleri takes
its opportunity passing into the brain
where it begins quite literally chowing
down on our gray matter the body react
swiftly sending a swarm of defensive
agents to help out the brain if that
sounds reassuring it shouldn't the
roughly seven millimeters of bone that
makes up the human skull is great for
protecting our most precious organs from
bumps and falls but it starts to
seriously work against us if the massive
neurons and blood inside begins to
increase in volume as the pressure
builds the brains connections the spinal
cord becomes disrupted and well all hell
breaks loose symptoms of Nigeria fowleri
infection include headache fever stiff
neck a loss
appetite alterations to the sense of
taste blurred vision loss of balance
seizures and hallucinations back in 2015
a man from Taiwan managed to stick out
this living nightmare for 25 days but
most patients will die within a week
thankfully whilst the amoeba itself is
relatively common infections in humans
occur only very rarely which is great
because since the amoeba was first
identified in 1965 around 99% of cases
have proven fatal which probably
shouldn't come as much as a surprise
when you consider that this thing
actually eats your brain next there's
the African sleeping sickness a
condition caused by the parasite
Trypanosoma brucei eye which makes its
way into us humans by way of a bite from
a testify one safely inside a blood
stream the parasite goes about feasting
on whatever nutrients it can find
they're causing fairly mild symptoms of
fever headaches and joint pain sounds
like a walk in the park compared to the
world's tiniest episode of The Walking
Dead that was denied Larry afoul Larry
right well not exactly
from here Trypanosoma brucei eye
undergoes a series of form changes
eventually reaching a state capable of
crossing the blood-brain barrier a
defensive mechanism designed to prevent
foreign substances from entering the
brain and central nervous system having
slipped past our defenses Japan Assam
abruzzi eye begins messing about with
the very fabric of what makes you well
you symptoms like confusion personality
changes tremors sleep disruption loss of
appetite and odd speech patterns soon
follow
if left untreated patients will become
slow and unresponsive eventually lapsing
into asleep from which they will never
wake up
death will soon follow the next and
final lovely parasite I'm delighted to
share with you is Toxoplasma gondii eye
and is perhaps the most interesting why
because there's a reasonable chance that
you yes you watching this video are
already infected with it estimates vary
as to just how much of the human
population is currently playing host to
a Toxoplasma gondii i party but some
studies suggest it could be as much as
30 to 50 percent and if that makes you
feel uncomfortable you'd better fasten
your seat belt remember how the lund set
liver fluke takes over the minds of ants
well Toxoplasma gondii I won't have you
climbing trees or trying to get yourself
ingested by a cow but it could change
your behavior in small but significant
ways the Toxoplasma gondii parasite is a
particularly adaptable little critter
and capable of taking up residence in
almost any warm-blooded animal a trait
that's extremely rare amongst parasites
but of all the creatures it can inhabits
there's only one in which it can
sexually reproduce arguably the most
cunning evil and downright me Mabel of
all the animals on earth they're not so
humble cat yes your cut may be carrying
a parasite that can alter the way you
think the muddled cut lady is a
well-trodden trope that's been around
for decades but it may be more accurate
than any of us previously fought the
typical life cycle of Toxoplasma gondii
i sees it's ingested by a small mammal
like a rat usually through contaminated
water or droppings
inside Toxoplasma gondii i spreads
throughout the rats body taking up
residence pretty much everywhere but
particularly in the brain where it forms
clusters of cysts in areas like the
amygdala which is responsible for the
brains fear response here
Toxoplasma gondii i whips out his
parasitical toolbox and gets busy
tinkering somehow rewiring the brain so
that instead of fearing the smell of cat
urine as rats instinctively do the host
rodent becomes sexually attracted to it
perhaps unsurprisingly developing a
fetish for cat piss
is one hell of a good way to get
yourself eaten by a cat and so the cycle
continues but as we've heard Toxoplasma
gondii AI isn't only carried by rats and
mice and it isn't only rodents as are
preyed upon by cats in the jungles of
Gabon
for example chimpanzees are preyed on by
leopards and guess what studies have
shown that chimps infected with
Toxoplasma gondii I become morbidly
attracted to the scent of leopard urine
making them much more likely to become
Leopard lunch and even animal as complex
and large brained as a chimpanzee can be
manipulated by this parasite it isn't
such a stretch to imagine that we might
be - we do share about 99% of the same
DNA
after all occupying a cozy spot at the
top of the food chain we modern humans
represent something of a dead end for
the Toxoplasma gondii eye parasite it's
going to struggle to convince us to be
eaten by a cat after all even if cats do
like to try every now and then but if we
go back far enough we too were prey for
big cats like cave lions saber-toothed
cats on false saber-toothed cats so is
Toxoplasma gondii i a parasite infecting
billions of people around the world
capable of actually changing our
behavior
believe it or not it just might be
research in this area though not yet
conclusive has hinted at some startling
findings suggesting that this incredibly
common parasite could well have an
impact on our appetite for risk our
moods our reaction times and even our
mental health one study discovered that
students in the u.s. who tested positive
for Toxoplasma gondii I were 1.4 times
as likely to be studying business and
one point seven times as likely to have
an educational emphasis in management
and entrepreneurship the same study
found that attendees at an
entrepreneurship event who tested
positive for Toxoplasma gondii I were
1.8 times as likely to have started
their own business compared to those who
tested negative
this trend holds true at the national
level too with countries with high
levels of Toxoplasma gondii eye
infections also showing increased
entrepreneurial activity so perhaps your
cat could make you a millionaire one day
then there's the research coming out of
Turkey that has shown those carrying
Toxoplasma gondii eye are as much as two
and a half times as likely to get into
traffic accidents meaning the parasite
may be responsible for hundreds of
thousands of road deaths worldwide each
year and yet another study that found
people with intermittent explosive
disorder which is surprisingly not to do
with the bowels but is a psychiatric
condition that leads to sudden outbursts
of rage like road rage were more than
twice as likely to test positive for
Toxoplasma gondii eye these behaviors
are strange indeed but all seem to be
linked to changes in our risk appetite
and natural human fear response
we know that Toxoplasma gondii i makes
my son's gyms less fearful in subtle but
important ways and it looks like it
might well be doing something similar
too
there's also growing evidence to suggest
that Toxoplasma gondii I may be linked
to psychological conditions like
schizophrenia with one study suggesting
the illness might be two to three times
as common in individuals testing
positive for the parasite versus the
rest of the population is it more than
just a coincidence then a schizophrenia
is thought to have become prominent in
the latter half of the 18th century
right around the time people in Paris
and London started keeping cats as pets
I'll let you be the judge of that
but the next time you flip someone the
bird when they cut you up on the
motorway or you wake up in the middle of
the night with a killer idea and the
strangers you quit your job and found
your first start up selling avocados to
Mexicans ask yourself one simple
question are you really calling the
shots
or is it your not-so-friendly brain
fungus thank you for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please consider
supporting me on patreon because it
really helped me to continue to make
them the links in the description also
you can get your hands on a first
edition signed copy of my new book
sticker flagging it
by heading on over to unbound delinked
in the description I'm pre-ordering your
copy today thank you